we have yet another victim of the Trump
tax cuts and they are the potential
employees of BMW who were not going to
be hired who are not going to get a job
because BMW is choosing to expand in
China instead of the United States so
for now BMW isn't reducing production in
the US although Trump has sort of talked
about getting German cars off American
roads which was really weird because a
lot of those companies employ many
American workers but BMW is choosing to
expand their manufacturing in China
instead of the United States and
starting next year BMW is going to
produce more than half a million cars in
China last year about a third of the
cars sold in China were actually
imported from other countries including
SUVs made in the United States and of
course as you probably know by now Trump
put a 25% additional tariff on thirty
four billion dollars in Chinese imports
this includes cars so China has also
retaliated when it comes to that and BMW
smartly obviously like I'm not cheering
it but I understand why they're doing it
they say well we're gonna avoid the
tariffs by making the cars that we sell
in China in China to begin with and
these are jobs that could have gone to
American workers Trump said he wanted to
help American workers but these are jobs
that are going to go to the Chinese
instead and yesterday I've been thinking
about what's the endgame here right how
can we get off of this escalating trade
war and contrary to what Trump said
trade wars aren't always good and
they're not always easy to win
but if they're going to end both sides
need to know what they need to have
happen in order to end them there's no
indication Trump knows what he would
need he's vaguely talked about China's
unfair to us on trade and they steal our
intellectual property ok well how do you
make that a policy if China just says we
won't steal intellectual property
anymore is that enough will that get
Trump to say we're ready to end this and
unfortunately there are lots of people
who are emailing me saying if only X
happened we could just undo these
tariffs and go back to where
I hate to break it to you but nearly a
dozen economic experts are saying that
once you have tariffs like these in
place it takes a while to remove them
and very often even before negotiations
happen around the tariff specifically
you'll see countries see if they can
maybe come to agreements on other things
sort of like proxy negotiations they're
stopped they're gonna start to feel out
can we cooperate on other geopolitical
issues if and when it feels like
progress has been made then you would
look at the idea of scaling down the
tariff so Trump very quickly
irrationally haphazardly started the
tariffs didn't seem like he knew much
about trade or what the impacts would be
and now we're going to be stuck with
this for a long time because these off
ramps can take a long time to actually
put in place and step one is the Trump
administration needs to be clear about
what they want it's not even clear that
they know it right now Trump says treat
us fairly on trade well what does that
look like Trump says China needs to stop
stealing intellectual property well what
does that look like when it comes to an
agreement and would he just take the
Chinese president's word on that they
don't know because they're clueless and
this was done haphazardly good luck
getting out of this anytime soon today's
program is made possible in part by
better help.com / Pakman this is
something I really believe in better
help gives you access to fully licensed
and experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer I have been talking for years
about the problem around people not
seeking help because of the stigma
around mental health services because of
the cost of mental health services and
all you have to do with better help is
go to better help calm slash Pakman
answer some basic questions you'll be
matched with a therapist that will be
right for you you can change therapists
if you don't think that it's a good fit
it's less expensive than seeing someone
in person you will still get the
professional help and it is unlimited
you can talk to a therapist everyday
from home or wherever you are go to
better help
/ Pakman it is so easy to sign up and
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube better help calm slash PA que ma
n if you've been wanting to talk to
somebody but for whatever reason haven't
please go to better help calm slash PA
que ma N